Amigos y amigas, hay episodios en la
historia argentina que solemos contar
como una estampa patriótica, pero que en
realidad son mucho más interesantes
cuando se los mira de cerca. Hoy vamos a
hablar de las invasiones inglesas. El
momento en que Buenos Aires fue ocupada,
el poder colonial quedó en crisis y una
ciudad que todavía no era capital de
ningún país empezó a descubrir que podía
defenderse sola. Una historia de
imperios, de milicias, comerciantes,
vecinos armados. Y una pregunta clave,
¿cuánto de la Argentina que vino después
empezó a cocinarse ahí antes de 1810?
¿Se lo contaremos nosotros?
Sí.
Gracias a que está Julia Rosen.
[aplausos]
Qué ganas de escuchar esta columna,
Julita.
Muchísimas, muchísimas.
Vos sabés que tiraste una pregunta
fundamental
y la última que tiraste, que es un poco
esa, ¿no? Repetila. ¿Querés?
¿Cuánto de la Argentina que vino después
empezó a cocinarse ahí?
Tal cual. Creo que es un poco así, ¿no?
Mañana se cumplen 220 años de la
reconquista. Sabemos las invasiones
inglesas fueron dos dos tandas. Vamos a
ver si fueron dos tandas o una. Pero
quiero decir, eh, el 12 de agosto de
1806 la primera el primer rechazo a las
invasiones inglesas que dimos en llamar
la reconquista. La segunda, 1807, es la
defensa. Bueno, mañana se cumplen 220
años de la primera, la reconquista. Y
tal cual, Pepigo, o sea, me parece que
en la pregunta que vos haces se esconde
algo de eso, ¿no? Hay una de las líneas
marca la línea fundamental de la
política argentina, de nuestra identidad
política argentina, las invasiones
inglesas. Y [resoplido] me parece que si
nuestra cultura, la cultura escolar
pusieron pusimos en 1810 el origen de
nuestra patria, de nuestra identidad, me
parece que hay que pensar a las
invasiones inglesas como el origen del
origen, ¿no? De alguna manera esa es la,
o sea, que el origen no es un acto
jurídico que le da forma a una nación,
sino el momento en que empezamos a
soñarla
o empezamos a pensar que era posible.
Exactamente. Sí. y empezamos a
ejecutarla también porque las invasiones
inglesas tienen mucho de eso. Vamos a
ver, vamos a a tratar de pensar qué
sucede en ese acontecimiento que marcó
tan profundamente. Y sin embargo,
decíamos, traje varios libros porque la
sensación es que sabemos poco de esas
invasiones inglesas, no tenemos como una
idea general, pero sin embargo eh nos
hemos acercado poco. Vamos a empezar
rápido, eh no tenemos mucho tiempo por
el contexto. Bueno, sí, pero quiero
decir, hay mucho para decir, entonces
vamos a tratar de condensar eh por el
contexto. ¿Qué es el contexto? ¿A qué me
refiero con el contexto? Bueno,
obviamente las potencias europeas,
estamos en un momento, la modernidad
podríamos decir, donde las potencias
europeas ordenan el mundo y compiten por
ese orden del mundo. Y hay una larga
enemistad entre fundamentalmente España
y Gran Bretaña. Larguísima enemistad.
¿Cuándo? Si tuviéramos que fecharla
siglo XV, diríamos, por ejemplo, la
guerra de religiones en Gran Bretaña eh
con el protestantismo, España con el
catolicismo. Sin duda, desde ahí hay una
enemistad muy clara, pero sumado a eso y
con el correr del tiempo, lo que va a
pasar es que eh el poderío militar,
mercantil e incipientemente industrial
de Gran Bretaña y su expansión por el
mundo va a ser va ahora a dar en gran
medida al Imperio español, ¿no? Es
decir, que mientras que un imperio está
en decadencia, el otro empieza a crecer,
¿no? como una época que se apaga y una
época que eh está inaugurándose entre
fines del siglo XVI, comienzos del siglo
XIX, que es justo el momento de las
invasiones inglesas, ¿no? Además, bueno,
hay que sumar cosas, lo digo rápido como
datitos para ir a buscarlos después. En
todo caso es también el momento de la
Revolución Francesa, por un lado, 1789,
que viene a complejizar la figura de
Napoleón, todo ese quilombo europeo.
[resoplido] Es también la independencia
de los Estados Unidos a partir de 1776,
que era colonia británica. Claro,
es también una batalla fundamental que
es la batalla de Trafalgar, que es muy
importante esta batalla, 1805, un año
antes de la invasión, porque es la
batalla donde se se enfrentan Francia,
España juntas contra Inglaterra. Es una
batalla naval donde Inglaterra los
despedaza y lo que sucede es que
Inglaterra queda dueña de los mares del
mundo, básicamente se expande por todos
los mares del mundo, ya sin ningún tipo
de problema y además genera para España,
que se queda prácticamente sin eh sin
barcos, genera una complicación entre la
comunicación y el comercio, entre la
metrópoli y sus colonias. Bien,
gran parte del tesoro de estas colonias
empieza a acumularse en el Río de la
Plata, ¿no? Entonces, bueno, es un
momento donde estas tierras parecen ser
apetecibles, vamos a decirlo así. En
1776 se había creado el virreinato del
Río de la Plata, su capital es la ciudad
de Buenos Aires. Eh, y se había creado,
entre muchas otras cosas, habría que
hacer un día una columna sobre el
virreinato del Río de la Plata. se había
creado, entre muchas otras cosas, por la
amenaza de Brasil, ¿no? Brasil, colonia
portuguesa, aliada siempre con
Inglaterra, quería expandir sus dominios
hacia el sur y por eso, en buena medida
también se quera el virran de Rival
Plata para
taponear. Exactamente. Hacia 1806. De
todas maneras esta era una zona
relativamente marginal y donde se suele
decir había una siesta colonial, ¿no? No
pasaba demasiado, se la suele una
caricatura que se la suele eh contar de
esa manera, no pasaba demasiado por
estas zonas que eran más bien marginales
de lo que todo el resto de Sudamérica.
Hasta junio de 180.
¿Quién gobierna esta parte del
territorio? Birrey Sobremonte
que dicen que comienzos medi de junio
empieza a recibir noticias de que hay
barcos de guerra ingleses merodeando la
zona y el tipo dice,
"No pasa nada,
deben ser contrabandistas como estamos
acostumbrados digamos, no pasa nada, si
van a ir, van a ir a Montevideo."
Entonces, el 27 de junio está Sobremonte
mirando una obra de teatro que se
llamaba El sí de las señoritas, mira,
de humor bastante tontuelo. Bueno, el
champán las pone mimosas de 1806.
[risas]
Está sofich.
Creo que su humor es mejor todavía. Y en
el medio de la obra de teatro tienen que
interrumpirlo al Brey para decirle Brey.
Le quiero decir una cosa.
Los contrabandistas [risas] están
llegando. Bir rey.
Están adentro.
Están adentro. Sobre monte. Bueno,
obviamente tiene que interrumpir la
función de teatro y sale a armar con lo
que tiene a mano, que es muy poco, con
lo que tiene a mano, desorganizado,
improvisado, algún tipo de resistencia,
que como sabemos nosotros con Belgrano,
por la columna que hicimos sobre
Belgrano en su autobiografía, Belgrano
cuenta de ese momento porque él rápido
quiere ir a defender a
defender
y Belgrano lo que se encuentra es un
desorganización total, una improvisación
muy grande. Enojadísimo Belgrano. Pu es
una pregunta boluda y y quizás es un
ladrillazo que se puede googlear.
Sobremonte había nacido en territorio
americano. No, no, no. Mis reyes tienen
que ser de la metrópolis. Claro.
Eh, los funcionarios en general tienen
que ser nacidos en la en la metrópoli.
Entonces, Belgrano va a decir la
resistencia a la llegada inglesa al 27
de junio fueron unos fueguitos que
tiramos y que los ingleses se lo sacaron
de encima rápidamente. No pasó nada. Ahí
Belgrano dice, "Tenía sentí vergüenza,
sentí indignación de no saber nada de
las milicias y no poder combatirlos."
No, casi como ya advirtiendo Belgrano
que para poder ser libre hay que saber
defenderse, vale para todos los órdenes
de la vida. El 27 entonces entran los
ingreses, toman la ciudad sin combatir,
prácticamente sin combatir 1600 hombres
en una ciudad de hay discusión sobre los
números, pero 45,000 habitantes tenía en
ese entonces Buenos Aires, es decir, muy
poca cantidad para la cantidad de
habitantes. Ahora, ¿qué pasa? Es una
tropa, la inglesa muy experimentada, es
una tropa que con los Highlanders, el
regimiento número 71 aclamado, vienenían
de de Escocia, eh, pelearon con la
independencia norteamericana, pelearon
contra el ejército napoleónico, es
decir, son
Pero perdieron todos también, ¿o no?
Bueno, eh con el
Mira, mira, mira, sácale una foto.
[risas]
[grito ahogado]
Lo que sucede después, a partir de 27 de
junio es una conquista en regla. ¿Por
qué marco esto? Porque hubo muchas
discusiones acerca de si los británicos
venían a ayudarnos con nuestra propia
independencia, sacarnos encima con los
españoles para comerciar con ellos. Lo
cierto es que lo que sigue el 27 de
junio es una conquista en regla. El
comandante de las fuerzas británicas,
Berefort, se proclama gobernador de
estas tierras. Se incautan los bienes
públicos. Es decir, todo el accionar a
partir de entonces los británicos es el
de que han conquistado un territorio.
Mandan un barco a Inglaterra a avisar
que tienen nuevas nuevas conquistas y a
pedir refuerzos para estas tierras. Como
sabe que eso demora dos o tr meses, ese
ida y vuelta en barco en ese entonces,
lo que hacen es confirmar, ratificar las
instituciones españolas, los a los
funcionarios españoles, solo que ahora
bajo un peldaño, que es que están por
debajo de los españoles,
los pasaron a secretaría. Claro.
Exactamente. [risas]
Pero se sostiene una situación colonial.
Esto sigue siendo una colonia. no vienen
a ayudarnos con la independencia de los
ingleses en este momento. No pasa eso.
Sacan uno de los primeros decretos, un
primer bando, así se llamaba, que dice
lo siguiente: "Es la graciable intención
de su majestad británica abrir un
comercio libre y permitido semejante al
de las otras colonias inglesas. Vienen a
hacer eso. Al igual que con las otras
colonias inglesas, esta colonia inglesa
ahora va a tener libre comercio." Digo,
para que no queden dudas de qué vienen a
hacer los ingleses a estas tierras. Al
día siguiente se hiza la bandera
británica en el fuerte y el 5 de julio
hacen jurar juran
buena parte de los funcionarios del
birriento de ese entonces le juran
lealtad al rey británico, a Jorge
Tercero, ¿no? Por supuesto, eh todo esto
genera una situación eh un poco da
cuenta un poco de la debilidad en la que
ya estaba el birreinato, porque para que
de un día para el otro pasen a jurar por
otro rey es es fuerte. Y además los
ingleses, los militares ingleses pasan a
vivir en las casas de la alta sociedad
de Buenos Aires. Forman parte de las
tertulias, de los bailes, en sus casas,
¿no? Empieza a ver como un nuevo como si
un nuevo orden se hubiese instalado sin
ningún tipo de sacudón, ¿no? Como si
nada hubiera pasado.
Y los reciben.
Y los reciben y el colmo de los colmos
es que la autoridad política que debería
defender, resistir esta invasión, el
birrey sobremonte, huye a Córdoba con el
tesoro.
Por supuesto. Este, acá estamos viendo a
a Sobremonte, Albrey.
Y era con su cuñado. No,
no sé. Lo del cuñado es un dato que no
no tenía.
Entonces, Jul. No, no, pero puede ser
puede ser tranquilamente creo que era su
cuñado que era también eh Bueno, no me
voy a meter en el lam de la historia
[risas] del
y se va con el tesoro, o sea,
supuestamente se va a parar resguardar
el tesoro de las nuevas autoridades,
cosa que no va a poder terminar de de
resguardarlas porque el tesoro el tesoro
termina yendo a a Gran Bretaña, pero
supuestamente se va eh armar tropas para
efectivamente resistir. pasa que lo hace
con una lentitud desesperante, por
supuesto, rápidamente para la población
de Buenos Aires pasa a ser un cobarde y
y un traidor, obamente no no no va a
haber dudas demasiado de esto. Vicente
Fidel López, uno de los autores que
quería recomendarles hoy, que es
realmente una de las cosas mejores
escritas que hay en la historia
argentina, un poco sale al mismo momento
que los libros de Mitre, o sea, está en
diálogo con los libros de Mitre. Vicente
Fidel López, historia de la República
Argentina, en su primer tomo le dedica
muchas páginas a las invasiones inglesas
y dice, "1806 producto de un cruce entre
un tonto y un loco.
El tonto es sobremonte, que va a decir
Vicente Fidel López, tuvo todas las
señales de alarma de que la invasión
estaba por suceder y no hizo nada y fue
incapaz de organizar una defensa. Y el
loco es Popham. ¿Quién es Popham? Popham
es el británico arquitecto de esta
invasión.
que desde hace muchos años venía
insistir, ahí estamos viendo eh una pose
muy canchera Popham que venía
insistiendo desde hace mucho tiempo con
esta invasión. Eh, él dudaba de si tenía
que ser que garantizar la independencia
o no, pero bueno, finalmente termina
siendo una conquista y por supuesto la
forma de convencer que tenía Popham a
todos es del tesoro que se iban a
llevar, el botín que se iban a llevar de
estas tierras fundamentalmente.
O sea, venían a robar,
venían a Sí. A comer, sí. Sí. El
contraband, sí, sí. [risas]
Ah. ¿Para
qué? ¿Para qué poner no metáforas? Eh,
lo que me interesaba decir es eh Popham,
¿por qué le dicen loco Vicente Fideló?
Porque porque Popham viene sin
autorización oficial, o sea, el tipo se
manda como un pirata. Efectivamente, va
con una eh con una misión a África a
Cabo de la Esperanza, de la buena
esperanza, y de ahí se manda para acá
con 1600 tipos. El rey no sabía que
el rey no sabía que esto estaba pasando,
estaba había dudas y demás, pero no
tenía autorización oficial de esto.
Dos boludos y un loco. Entonces, ya. Sí,
[risas] claro.
Sí. Lo que interesa del tonto y el loco
es eh en todo caso esa tontera y esa
locura eran expresiones de cosas más
grandes. La tontera, probablemente un
imperio en decadencia y la locura de un
imperio con una visión impresionante,
¿no?
¿Qué cómo recibe la ciudad todo esto?
Porque hasta ahora hablamos de las
clases dominantes, hablamos de los
funcionarios, hablamos de los
británicos. ¿Cómo recibe la ciudad todo
esto? Es difícil saber. Bartolomé Mitre
dice así: "Los hombres lloraban de
vergüenza por las plazas y las calles,
¿no? O sea, sin dar pelea vienen y te
invaden 1600 tipos y además tus
conductores que tienen que defenderte te
las toman." Claro.
Un testimonio de la época, otro libro
que recomendamos, testimonio de Ignacio
Núñez, eh escribe en en el momento,
poquito tiempo después, va a decir, "El
sentimiento de humillación fue el único
que formó todas las conciencias. No, es
decir, lo que se instala en el pueblo de
Buenos Aires en ese entonces es nos
humillaron, ¿no? Nos humillaron
y esto va a empezar a aparecer muy
rápido, apenas 5 horas después de la
invasión. Guilespi, que es otro que va a
escribir sus memorias, tenemos muchas
memorias por suerte, y esto hace de de
todo esto muy muy lindo, muy gráfico.
Gilespi es un británico que viene a
estas tierras y escribe poquito tiempo
después sus memorias. va a contar que él
como militar inglés va a ir con sus
compañeros a una fonda, a un restaurant
cerca del fuerte a ir a comer. Y vamos a
ver una escena de una película que se
llama la película La muerte en las
calles del año 1952. ¿Qué sucede cuando
Guilespi va con los británicos al
restaurant a comer?
[música]
Así
todo
por mí que se mueran
Cuidado, Marcela.
Estos herejes hablan en gringo. ¿Qué van
a entender?
Yo entiendo, señorita. Cuidado,
señores.
¿Vamos a llevarnos bien? ¿Qué les
parece?
Nos conviene a todos.
¿Tiene
algo para comer que no tenga veneno?
Señor, por causa de todo esto,
comprendas, la ciudad está mal
abastecida y no encontramos qué poderle
ofrecer.
Jamón con huevos.
Ah, eso sí, eso sí.
A la cocina. A la cocina. A la cocina.
Siempre está mala.
Yo creí que las criollas.
Oiga, mister, no. Algún día vas a ver lo
que valemos las criollas.
Vamos, Marcelo. [risas]
Bueno, esta película es del año 1952,
de las pocas películas que hay sobre la
muerte en las calles, que está basada en
una novela de Manuel Gálvez, del mismo
del mismo nombre, la novela Las muertes
en las calles, que a su vez las muertes
en las calles Galves están basadas en
las memorias de Guilespi, ¿no? Es como
Norma Leandro actúa en la película.
Mira, pero del 52 es la peli.
Mira, una jovencita normal. No la
reconocí,
evidentemente.
Mira. Y nada, me preguntaba por qué una
película sobre las invasiones inglesas
tuvo lugar en 1952. No hay muchas,
insisto, en el último tiempo salieron en
algunos documentales, eh, pero claro, el
gobierno de Perón en 1946 decreta
feriado nacional el 12 de agosto, es
decir, durante los años del peronismo es
una fecha a la que se le da mucha bola y
probablemente esta película tenga que
ver con eso.
Okay.
En el libro de de Guilespenta esta
anécdota. Él él es el que la trae y de
ahí la toma la película, pero la cuenta
un poco distinta. Dice que eh la
muchacha eh Manuela, no, Marcela,
perdón, Marcela, le dice lo siguiente,
le dice al criollo,
"Debería, desearía que ustedes,
caballeros, nos hubiesen informado con
anticipación de sus cobardes intenciones
de rendir Buenos Aires, pues apostaría a
mi vida que de haberlo sabido las
mujeres, nos habríamos levantado
unánimemente y rechazado a los ingleses
a pedradas, ¿no? Esta sensación de, ¿por
qué no nos convocaron al pueblo que
nosotros hubiésemos hecho otra cosa?"
Exactamente. Eh, me interesa estas
palabras de Marcela porque claro, eh,
son sintomáticas de un estado más
general, no son solamente las de
Marcela, sino que excede a Marcela. Casi
como si dijéramos, a veces lo que va a
pasar, el pulso de lo que va a pasar
está mucho más en la boca de una
trabajadora
de anónima que en cualquier otro lado,
¿no? Eh, vale para ayer, vale para hoy.
A 10 días de haber instalado, de haberse
instalado en la ciudad de Buenos Aires,
Bereford saca un decreto que tiene que
ver con las armas. ¿Qué pide Bereford?
Aquellos que no cumplan tienen pena de
muerte. Lo que va a decir Bford es
tienen que entregar todas las armas.
¿Por qué? Porque Bford sabe que hay
armas desperdigadas por toda la ciudad y
que esconder armas forma parte de una
forma de resistencia que en cualquier
momento se te puede volver en contra.
Saca este bando y nadie entrega las
armas. Entonces, Bereford empieza a
sospechar de que efectivamente hay una
resistencia que se está activando por
abajo y que es necesario cortarla cuanto
antes. Y efectivamente ya había empezado
a organizarse. Tres caminos tiene esta
resistencia. Uno es un plan del que se
conoce poco y nada, que es un plan que
empezó a hacerse y no se no se terminó,
que es fue cavar dos túneles
para hacer volar por los aires los dos
lugares claves que tenían los ingleses
con los ingleses adentro, por supuesto.
Uno era el regimiento del 71, donde
estaban los Highlanders, hacerlo volar
por los aires y el otro era el fuerte,
donde estaba la residencia de Bford. Se
llegaron a acabar los túneles, no se
llegaron a hacerlos explotar. Martín de
Álzaga, si tenemos una imagen de él para
poner en pantalla, es quien financia
estos túneles que no llegaron a hacerse
porque la reconquista eh llega antes,
pero esta es una de las formas de
resistencia que se encontraron en ese
momento, que también habla un poco del
estado de ánimo del pueblo, ¿no? Ganas
de hacer volar por los aires a los
ingleses. El segundo camino de
resistencia fue por el de Porredón, que
Porredón en la zona de Perdriel empieza
a juntar gauchos de la campaña para
hacerle frente en batalla a los
ingleses. Los ingleses se enteran de que
eso está pasando. El primero de agosto
los enfrentan y los derrotan muchísimo.
Y la tercera vía resistencia es la que
encabeza ahora sí Santiago de Liniers,
el que va a ser llamado, si podemos
poner en pantalla su imagen, el héroe de
la de la Reconquista. Eh,
Linier, ¿quién es? Es un francés eh al
mando que está bajo las órdenes del
Imperio Español. Es un comandante, hasta
ese momento poco no tenía ningún tipo de
relieve. tiene 50 años en este momento,
es un ya grande
y es este acontecimiento el que lo deja
en la historia de alguna manera, hasta
antes no había pasado nada. Se pone al
mando entonces también de una de las
vías de resistencia y lo que hace antes
de irse a Montevideo a buscar refuerzos
de hombres es ir a la iglesia de Santo
Domingo, que va a ser muy importante en
todo esto, a jurarle a la Virgen del
Rosario que le pide ayuda, que se ponga
del lado nuestro y le dice que si ella
lo ayuda, le va a traer banderas
ingleses, inglesas como una ofrenda.
cosa que efectivamente va a terminar eh
sucediendo. Entonces, Linier va a
Montevideo, consigue hombres por parte
de Ruis Widobro y cuando está volviendo
lo que está lo que pasa cuando Linier va
a enfrentarse a los ingleses el 12 de
agosto, lo que empieza a pasar es que se
le empieza a sumar muchísima multitud
fuera del ejército regular, ¿no? Se le
empieza a sumar gente que dice,
"Nosotros que también queremos combatir
ahora sí, ¿no?" Entonces, lo que empieza
a pasar es que eh la avanzada de Linear
se empieza a ver sobrepasada por la
multitud. Ya no es un ejército en regla,
ya no son milicias, es pueblo que
quiere, tiene ganas de echar a los
ingleses. Y lo que le pasa a Lineers es
que plantea la batalla para el 12 de
agosto, pero la gente empieza a accionar
antes,
sin orden,
como el paro del 18 de octubre que se
hace,
que se hace antes, tal cual. Hay un
testimonio de Francisco Saguí que dice
lo siguiente. Guerrillas que
voluntariamente se formaban y destacaban
los mismos vecinos que sin orden ni
disciplina acechaban y avanzaban con
puñal en mano matando a los centinelas
avanzados. Todo esto sin orden de
Lineers. Está desbordada la resistencia
a los ingleses. Otra Manuela Pedraza,
¿no? La que tiene una calle acá en la
ciudad de Buenos Aires. Otra tanto, una
mujer que no formaba parte de ningún
ejército de línea. Dice Mitre, combatió
en ese día al lado de su marido. Mató
con sus propias manos a un soldado
inglés, Manuela Pedraza, y después le
entregó el fusil a Liners y Linés la
reconoció como soldado y le hicieron eh
grandes grandes homenajes. No quiero
decir.
Manuela Pedraza mató con sus manos a un
soldado inglés y era una mujer random de
Buenos Aires.
Random. Marcela, la que vimos recién,
también formó parte de todo esto. Es
eso, la resistencia al
Yo no voy a ir por esa calle nunca más
como
No, para nada. [risas]
Vas a estar con ganas que aparezca un
inglés.
Sí. sacando pecho.
Por eso la resist la reconquista,
perdón, en gran medida fue obra del
pueblo, fue parte del pueblo de la
ciudad de Buenos Aires y de los
alrededores de la ciudad de Buenos Aires
con la aparición de este nuevo actor. Si
esto era una batalla en regla,
claro,
eh, ejército contra ejército, podía
estar liberado de la suerte de
cualquiera. El que termina de definir la
batalla para un lado es la aparición de
esta multitud indómita, indisciplinada.
No lo va a decir Ramos Mejía, que aparte
Ramos Mejía tiene una lectura muy
interesante, que es porque Ramos Mejía
lo que va a decir es mientras las clases
dominantes
tranzaban, entregaban,
realidad, claro, él va a decir, "Son
soldados humildes, vecinos y hombres
anónimos cuantos inician y organizan la
reconquista.
Hervían el seno de la muchedumbre el más
vivo entusiasmo por la venganza,
mientras las clases superiores y los
burgueses ricos y meticulosos habían
resuelto aceptar los hechos consumados."
Claro, ¿qué autoridad te queda para
seguir con el virreinato después de eso?
también
total. Bueno, eso vamos a ver ahora qué
sucede después, ¿no? Pero me interesa
marcar esto, ¿no? El pueblo aporta una
indisciplina que, claro, va a decir
Ramos Mejía, todas las ventajas que la
disciplina y la táctica daban a los
veteranos ingleses quedaban anuladas,
¿no? Frente a esta esta cosa
desorganizada que tiene el pueblo
argentino, no sirve la disciplina
inglesa y británica del ejército
profesional. Punto.
Claro.
Fíjense como narra Sobremonte a España,
le manda un informe de cómo fue esta
batalla, de cómo fue la victoria y dice
así: "Consumo desorden, sin un plan que
merezca el nombre de militar y así
milagrosamente por el aturdimiento del
enemigo al ver todo un pueblo conjurado
contra ellos, ¿no? Obviamente Sauremonte
hablando mal de lo que pasó, diciendo,
"Qué desastre esto que fue así." Sin
embargo, acá hay algo hermoso de lo que
está diciendo, ¿no? Fue todo un pueblo
contra un el ejército de la mayor
potencia del mundo, nada más ni nada
menos. Y Sorremonte, ¿dónde estaba? En
este momento
Sorremonte sigue en Córdoba. Va a venir,
va a intentar volver después. Ahora
vamos a ver eso. Lo que me interesa
marcar es esto. El 12 de agosto Bford no
tuvo más, ante este escenario no tuvo
más remedio que rendirse. Una vez que
entra al fuente, al al fuerte, perdón, a
a negociar con Lines, cómo va a ser la
rendición, tienen que parar al pueblo
para que no entre el fuerte a matarlos a
todos. Estaba desaforada la multitud,
¿no? O sea, porque aparte victoriosa,
¿no? Va a decir Vicente Fidel López, fue
la primera vez en memoria de escocés
alguno que sus gaitas no hubiesen
celebrado la victoria. No es la primera
vez que los escoceses pierden algún tipo
de batalla y la pierden nada más ni nada
menos que con el pueblo argentino.
Probablemente exagere Vicente Fidel
López, pero qué cucarda, ¿no?
Nos quedamos con [risas] eso.
Los argentinos y los chupate [risas]
si podemos ver el cuadro de la
Reconquista, es un cuadro bastante
conocido. El el pintor es un pintor
francés. Charles, lo voy a mencionar
mal, perdón.
Son los dos países en el planeta
enfrentaron al Reino Unido de Gran
Brentania, los Ulúes y los argentinos.
Yo pensé, yo pensé también.
Este cuadro es de 1909, lo vemos a
Liniers, ¿no? Y a Bereford que está
rindiéndose. Lo que me interesa de este
cuadro, de los cuadros de Foker en
general, es que la época del centenario,
¿no? Momento de la oligarquía argentina
y demás, están ellos dos, está Bereford
y está Lineer, pero lo que resalta no
son ellos dos, lo que resalta es la
multitud. Hay que hacer foco para verlos
ellos dos tratar de concentrarse para
donde están. Lo que resalta es esa
multitud y es esa multitud desorganizada
para Y este es Bereford rindiéndose.
Exactamente. Es la Reconquista. Es el
día de la Reconquista.
Y Bereford, ¿cuál de los dos es en el
cuadro? Perdón, Julita,
el Lineers es el que está como de
espaldas así. Y el colorado, claro, el
pelado.
Colado, el pelado.
Otra imagen que nos tenemos que porque
yo siempre que digo no hay imagen,
después viene y me dicen, "No, pero hay
un colage que hicimos no sé dónde." Yo
cuando digo no hay imágenes, quiero
decir que no hay imágenes que hayan
quedado en la cultura argentina, ¿no? O
sea, a eso quiero decir. No hay imágenes
de esto, pero son imágenes que nos
tenemos que construir con palabras
porque son muy lindas, que es que uno de
los barcos puestos en el río para
cañonar a la multitud para evitar el
enfrentamiento con los ingreses, un
barco que tenía 26 cañones. Sucede que
cuando el mismo 12 se retira la
sudestada, queda encallado
eh en cerca del puerto un barco que se
llamó Justine, probablemente la
pronunciación inglés sea otra, pido
disculpas, queda encallado y como quedó
encallado, aprovechan unos hombres de a
caballo, unos hombres hombres de la
caballería para subirse al barco y
rendir el barco.
Entre ellos, ¿quién estaba
el que comanda esta acción inédita?
Porque nunca la marina es derrotada por
la caballería. No existe eso en la
historia de la militar de la humanidad.
Sí, sí.
La comandó el joven saltenio de 20 años,
20 pico de años, Martín Miguel de Gües,
que luego se va a convertir en el héroe,
uno de [resoplido] los grandes héroes de
nuestra liberación. Imagen buenísima.
Era un niño subido a caballo en un barco
inglés.
¿Y qué hacía en Buenos Aires? vino a
formarse también eh un año antes, si no
me equivoco, estaba en Buenos Aires
formándose en las milicias, parte de de
las tropas, ¿no? Al día siguiente ahora
lo que
digo el momento que estás a caballo
decir, vamos a tomar ese barco, [risas]
¿en qué momento te viene esa decisión?
¿En qué momento le caballo subí? No,
[risas]
al día siguiente vamos a lo que
preguntaba Mati antes, ¿no? Se convoca
un cabildo abierto. Cabildo abierto, ¿a
qué nos asoamos nosotros cabildo
abierto? Semana de mayo de 1810. El 22
de mayo,
exactamente, hay un cabildo abierto en
1806 al día siguiente de la victoria,
donde se discute que se sabe que va a
haber una nueva ofensiva, el tema va a
ser cómo defenderse.
¿Por qué se sabe?
Porque se fueron hasta ahí no más porque
se sabía que habían pedido refuerzos de
Gran Bretaña, que esos refuerzos iban a
llegar en cualquier momento.
Entonces, eh, perdón, la eh la
reconquista termina con 45 días de
ocupación de Inglaterra en estas
tierras. Fueron 45 días de ocupación,
¿no? Entonces, lo que
bandera británica flameando.
Sí, sí, sí. autoridades, bando, sacando
decretos, todos se llevaron el tesoro,
se llevaron nuestros bienes, todo.
Y es verdad que designaron a un Martínez
de OS,
¿no? En no sé, posible. Sí, te pido
disculpas. No, bueno,
yo los libros que leí me los regalaste
[risas] vos.
[grito ahogado]
Me interesa marcar esto. Eh, lo que se
empieza a discutir en este cabildo
abierto es cómo defenderse, ¿no? Cómo
hacer para ante la segunda nuevada
defenderse, porque no hay duda. Ahora,
eh, la lo que no duda la multitud, 4,000
tipos se congregan en el cabildo
abierto. Es decir, una multitud enorme.
Sí, perdón.
¿Te puedo aportar un dato?
Sí, obvio.
En 180, durante la primera invasión
inglesa a Buenos Aires, el comerciante
español José Martínez de OS fue nombrado
administrador de aduanas por la fuerza
de ocupación británica. Tranqui.
Tras haber colaborado con los invasores
y jurado lealtad a la corona británica.
200 años jodiendo a este
qué prontuario. [música][canto]
Llegó a Buenos Aires. Llegó a Buenos
Aires desde Castilla la vieja en el
siglo XVI y mi ley es una basura.
Mira eso dice [risas]
Google,
¿no? Y también se decía que era
traficante de esclavos.
Mi ley.
No. [risas]
Ah, boluda, me asusté. La madre.
[risas]
¿Qué sucede en este cabildo abierto
donde se quiere discutir cómo defenderse
de la segunda invasión? La multitud
decía, "4000 tipos, dice Mitre, eh, 4000
tipos para la época es un montón afuera
del cabildo. Dicen que no vuelva sobre
monte, sobre todo que no vuelva sobre
monte. [risas]
Es Liners, es por ahí,
porque la audiencia, que es la que
garantiza los los intereses del rey,
dice, no, que vuelva a Sobre Monte. De
ninguna manera. levantó la ocupación por
teléfono sobre
entonces insisten con que vuelva a
Sobremonte y esto enerva tremendo la
multitud que prácticamente ya está yendo
a buscar los palos. Claro, el tema es
cómo volver a establecer una obediencia
después de que el pueblo ya fue
protagónico de todo esto.
Claro. Sí. Si no es con linear, no es.
Si no es con linear, no es. Hay una
fuente maravillosa que se llama Diario
de un soldado, que es alguien anónimo
que escribió durante eh esos días, que
además es es del pueblo, formó parte de
las milicias de los patricios. Vos que
es muy difícil llegar, sino de otra
manera que lo cuenta así de esta manera
dice él. Se le preguntó al público si
debían eh dejar volver a Sobremonte.
Todos respondieron que no, no lo
queremos. Que muera ese traidor. Nos ha
vendido, es desertor. En el caso más
peligroso nos ha dejado. Se ha huido con
9,000 onzas de oro. Queremos a don
Santiago de Liniers Virrey. Y si intenta
sobre monte venir a gobernar, respondió
al pueblo que antes permitirían se le
cortaran a todos la cabeza.
Espectacular. alarma, porque claro,
¿quién cortó cabeza hace poco? La
Revolución Francesa. Entonces, esto es
una escena muy al borde, muy al borde de
la revolución. Ya. Claro. Y por
supuesto, tienen que dar marcha atrás y
nombran a Liners, es decir, estamos en
un momento revolucionario por excelencia
porque es el pueblo el que decide que
Sobremonte deje de ser birrey e imponen
un nuevo birrey. En el orden colonial,
esto es imposible, que sea el pueblo el
que decida. Por eso decimos que la
revolución de mayo tiene que ser vista a
la luz de las invasiones, del fuego que
abre las invasiones inglesas, que no se
apaga hasta mayo de 1810, sino que lo
que hace es darle otro canal. Pero sin
dudas acá está la revolución ya de
alguna manera, ¿no? Eh, estuve el fin de
semana en la iglesia de Santo Domingo
en
Defensa y Belgrano, en el barrio de
Santelmo. Y
fuiste a qué, Julita,
a ver las banderas. Bien,
porque en la iglesia de Santo Domingo
están las banderas que efectivamente
linear después de la Reconquista le
lleva a la Virgen de Rosario que les
robamos a los ingleses si podemos ver
las refeliz amiga. [risas]
Estos son los trapos que le robamos a
Inglaterra y están ahí,
¿sí? No, el fin de semana yo me cago
risa.
No, me parece espectacular.
Estos son los cuatro. Hay cuatro
banderas acá y dos en Córdoba que les
robamos a los ingleses. Exactamente. Una
de estas aparentemente es la que roba
Gües incluso de de del barco Justine.
Impresionante.
¿Y por qué están ahí, Julita?
Porque Linear se los se los otorga la
Virgen por haber ayudado a en la
batalla. No está la iglesia está
abierta, se puede ir a ver a cualquier
momento. Y en la iglesia de Santo
Domingo es muy importante en todo esto
porque está en el centro de Santelmo,
que fue donde se dirimió todas estas
batallas. fue en ese centro, ¿no?, donde
eh se enfrentaron uno y otro. Y quería
ver otra imagen, si podemos poner eh la
historieta de Wester Hel en 1974,
escribe una historieta que se llama 450
años de guerra y escribe, si podemos
poner el último cuadrito,
uno sobre las invasiones inglesas, donde
Juan le pregunta al padre, "Papá, ¿por
qué? ¿Para qué vienen los ingleses?" No,
eso le pregunta al papá y el papá le
contesta, "Para quitarnos el país, hijo,
para quitarnos a Cristo, son unos
herejes." ¿Qué me interesa esta
respuesta que da Ostergel que da a
través de del padre? Eh, claro, religión
y tierra, ¿no? Eso es lo que se pone en
juego ante esta invasión y eso me parece
recontrainteresante porque eh también
para explicar por qué fue tan
contundente la respuesta de nuestro
pueblo, ¿no? Porque estaba en juego nada
más ni nada menos que la religión y la
tierra. Cuando está en discusión la
tierra, no está solamente en discusión
los recursos naturales o eh un recurso
económico. Cuando está en discusión la
tierra, cuando está en disputa la
tierra, también está en disputa nuestra
fe, nuestras verdades. En nuestra tierra
está la sangre derramada de quienes nos
precedieron, está lo que nos hace común
y está nuestra historia. Por eso, eh
cuando está en disputa la Tierra, cuando
está en peligro la Tierra, la respuesta
es tan contundente por parte del pueblo
argentino hace 220 años y también en
tiempo presente. Vamos a ir a la Sí.
Pensé que era el final. Ese no es el
final. Entonces voy a aprovechar para
No, lo que va a ser el final. Ya estaba
para [risas]
Ya tenía las palmas preparadas.
Tiempoita.
Tenemos 220 años sobre nuestra espalda.
Amiga, [risas]
gente, cada vez que les preguntamos a
ustedes qué valoran de gelatina, en
todas las encuestas que hacemos, en
todos nuestros focus group, lidera las
columnas de historia de Julita
Rosenberg. Así que primero quiero
aplaudir a Julita Rosita [aplausos]
[ovación]
que nos tiene así. Así durante 40
minutos diciendo, "Ojalá los hayamos
sacado estos ingleses [risas] de
mierda." Y a ustedes quiero decirles que
la mejor manera de valorar este espacio
que son 40 minutos, a veces 50, a veces
una hora hablando de corrido de historia
de la mano de una pero historiadora
espectacular como Julia Rosenberg es
asociarse a gelatina. Esto no pasa en
otro lado. En otros lados pasan otras
cosas muy valiosas también, pero acá
pasa esto. Julita Rosemer, hoy
invasiones inglesas. La última vez el
encuentro en Guayaquil. 200.000 personas
vieron el encuentro en Guayaquil de
Julitan. No es un chiste, Julita, eh, no
es un chiste. Eh,
eh, muchos compañeros latinoamericanos
la vieron.
Me imagino, imagino, me imagino. Eh,
bueno, y como esto te puedo nombrar 1000
ejemplos de las columnas de Julita que
realmente vuelan. 210,000 personas
vieron tu columna de Guayaquil. Si había
más personas mirando la columna que en
Guayaquil en ese momento, [risas]
Julito.
Belgrano, 70 años de los fusilamientos.
¿Qué fue el Belgrano? ¿La vió? ¿Qué fue
el cordobazo?
[risas]
la lucha detrás del primero de mayo.
Bueno, en fin, amigos, se asocian a
gelatina si ustedes valoran este
contenido que para nosotros es de
calidad, de calidad en cuanto a
divulgación, en cuanto también
entretenimiento, porque sabemos que
están del otro lado agarrados así e y en
cuanto también a una decisión política
que es que el pasado, que la historia
converse con nuestro presente. Entran a
gelatina.com.ar o escanean el QR que
figura en pantalla. Perdón, Julita,
no, por favor. No, para recomendar
también la biografía de Santiago de
Linear que escribió Paul Grusac eh a
comienzo del siglo XX, que es
recontrainesante. Sí, está buenísima. Es
recontrainesante. Eh, voy rápido con la
segunda invasión. Eh, hay, como sabemos,
hay una segunda misión. Decimos, es
parte de la misma. ¿Por qué? Porque e,
perdón, ¿en qué época del año fue? ¿Pasó
un año o fue? Pasó un año, lo que sucede
es lo siguiente. Como sabemos, las
distancias en ese momento eran dos o
tres meses de ida ida y vuelta, ¿no? O
sea, la comunicación al gobierno
británico de que las invasiones las
habían ganado en junio del 6 le llegan
en septiembre, ¿no?
Y en octubre recién están en condiciones
de mandar refuerzos, es decir, que
llegan a estas a estas tierras en
febrero
y cuando llegan en febrero, lo primero
que hacen es eh invadir sobre todo
Montevideo, ¿no? Primero lo que hacen es
tomar Montevideo. Eh, por supuesto,
además, la noticia a Gran Bretaña llega
junto con el tesoro, así que están
contentísimos. Ya se olvidaron de la
desobediencia de Popham, que en un
momento querían juzgar, se olvidan de
todo, eh, y lo que hacen es ahora el
mando de Whlock es otro, ya no es Bford,
es Whlock el que está al mando de las
tropas eh británicas. Una un contingente
de 9000 tipos vienen, desembarcan a
comienzo de julio en Ensenada,
con todo. Ahora,
¿qué pasa? Nosotros no nos quedamos
atrás porque a partir de ese cabildo
abierto donde se está discutiendo cómo
resistir a la segunda invasión, Buenos
Aires se militariza. O sea, es cuestión
de darle orden, de darle disciplina a
esa multitud indisciplinada se le
empieza a dar algún tipo de cause eh
militar, ordenado y disciplinado, ¿no?
Entonces, lo que hacen Lineers y la
Junta de Guerra es armar las milicias,
milicias que van a estar ordenadas por
lugar de nacimiento. Entonces, van a
estar las milicias españolas, las
milicias americanas, los patricios, los
arribeños, bueno, distintos tipos de
batallones. que es muy interesante.
8,000 tipos armados, 8,000 tipos armados
en una sociedad, decíamos, de 45,000
habitantes donde donde el 30% eran
esclavos, además,
¿no? Entonces es una proporción muy
grande. Y de los 8,000 5,000 eran
americanos. Es decir,
de los 45,000 tipos, el 30% eran
esclavos.
Sí.
Y los 8000 eh armados formaban parte del
restantes.
Sí, lo que pasa es que algunos esclavos
formaron parte, pero no no era el grueso
ni ni cerca, ¿no? O sea, participaron,
pero de otra manera los esclavos en todo
esto. Lo que me interesa junto con Alper
Perindongi, este libro genial que se
llama Revolución y Guerra, ¿qué dice el
Perindongiu? Dice, "La elite colonial no
va a ver bien todo este proceso de
militarización para nada." No
cita dice así, el punto de partida de
una suerte de revolución social. ¿Por
qué? Porque ahora tenés ciudadanos en
armas, que además son los ciudadanos del
bajo pueblo los que se alistan porque
cobran un salario.
Entonces, en el cobrar un salario, lo
que va a suceder es que gran parte del
dinero que antes iba a la metrópoli,
ahora queda en la colonia y además queda
en la colonia en los sectores más
humildes. Es una suerte de
redistribución de la riqueza. Fenomenal
lo que genera todo esto y no solamente
redestrucción de la riqueza, sino que
además otro hecho fundamental es que los
jefes de estas milicias las van a elegir
los propios soldados,
¿no? Un peligro. el primer ejercicio de
democracia en estas tierras directo
asambleario dentro del estado, o sea,
soldados eligiendo sus jefes, lo que
también le abre la puerta a que entren a
a a la a que entren a ser jefes y lo que
empieza a ser el bajo pueblo. Entonces,
empieza a llegar los que no están
preparados, ¿no? Empieza a llegar eh los
hombres oscuros, empiezan a decir, no,
todo un problema. Pero por supuesto es
un nuevo equilibrio de de de fuerzas en
estas tierras.
Linear le va a escribir una carta a
Napoleón que dice lo siguiente: "La
subordinación tan necesaria para hacer
obrar ejércitos con utilidad, ¿cómo
podía establecerse entre gentes que se
creen todos iguales?" No, genial. Entre
gentes que se creen todos iguales, ¿no?
Efectivamente, hay algo de eso en el
pueblo de estas tierras que ya comienza
a vislumbrarse. Rápido, primeros meses
de 1807. Entonces, decíamos eh
desembocan acá en Enenada. Eh lo que
sucede es que Lineers da eh batalla en
Miserere, pero le pifia.
y pierde esa batalla. Con lo cual la
defensa, si la reconquista fue obra de
Lineers y junto con la multitud, la
defensa va a ser obra fundamentalmente
del pueblo de los vecinos de la ciudad
de Buenos Aires con Alsaga detrás, pero
acá cambia que había financiado los
Exactamente. Exactamente. En los dos
casos, en uno y otro, el protagonista es
el pueblo, ¿no? Liners tuvo más
condiciones en uno, alzaga en este otro.
¿Qué le pasó a Liners en el medio, che?
Sí, la epifión en una cuestión militar,
digamos, puede pasar tranquilamente. Lo
que hace el ejército británico es se
dividen 13 columnas que van por las
calles de Santelmo, lo que hay Santelmo,
¿no? Por esas calles fundamentalmente. Y
lo que va a decir Guilesp
eh fue atacado desde las viviendas. El
gran secreto fue que los que atacaban a
los ingleses estaban en las viviendas.
Va a decir Guilespi, una terrible
descarga de un enemigo oculto,
inaccesible. Claro, estaban en las
terrazas, estaban en los balcones, no se
los veía. Entonces los escuchaba y de
repente con todo, ¿no? Algunos dicen,
"Exageran el número, pero no tanto."
3000 bajas a los ingleses. 3000 muertos
se produce en los ingleses donde se les
tira, como sabemos, de todo. Madera, eh
agua, agua hirviendo, se le tira de
todo, de las azoteas, además de los
tiros de los soldados, pero
fundamentalmente se le tira de todas las
azoteas y finalmente encerrados en la
iglesia de Santo Domingo, Whiteck se eh
se rinde. Vamos a ver el cuadro. Acá
está puesto. Buenísimo. Este es el otro
cuadro, el de la defensa cuando se
rinde.
Qué buen cuadro, Julita,
buenísimo. También del mismo autor, ¿eh?
También de la época de del centenario
finalmente.
¿Y quién es el el digamos el que está en
el centro?
El que está a caballo es Liniers,
nuevamente de espaldas y el que está
mirando como de abajo medio enfrentado a
Liniers es Whiteck, el nuevo eh el que
comandó ahora esta segunda etapa. Bueno,
se rinden y finalmente esta rendición
hasta le dice, "Te vas de acá, te vas de
Montevideo, te vas del Río de la Plata."
Se va. Es como una es una derrota
tremenda, vergonzosa. Whenefrentar un
juicio en Inglaterra. Bueno, eh nos
queda nos queda poco tiempo, ¿no es
cierto? No. Okay. No, entonces
sí. Felipe dice que para [risas] Bueno,
dale dale dale. White sí estaba
autorizado. O
claro, la segunda, la segunda invasión
está autorizada totalmente y traen los
refuerzos y todo. De todas maneras tiene
un juicio por haber sido derrotado, ¿no?
Claro.
Eh, cierro entonces en el origen del
origen. Voy a citar algunas cosas para
cerrar. Lo primero que me gustaría decir
es que ante la agresión de un invasor
externo con sus ecuaces internos, que
esto hay que aprenderlo, siempre sucede,
nuestro pueblo se constituyó como tal.
Ante la invasión, el pueblo de estas
tierras se constituye como tal. Vicente
Fidel López lo dice así. El comodoro
Popham había dirigido a sus soldados
sobre Buenos Aires sin haberse dado
cuenta de qué era el pueblo que quería
someter.
Es interesante porque en realidad nadie
sabía lo que era este pueblo, ni él
mismo sabía, ni el propio pueblo sabía
de lo que era capaz y de su potencia. Se
da cuenta este pueblo de lo que es y de
su enorme potencia en el mismo accionar,
en la misma experiencia de vida, en el
mismo acontecimiento que fueron las
invasiones inglesas. Por eso las
invasiones inglesas son tan relevantes
para nuestra historia, porque es el
momento en que el pueblo argentino, el
pueblo que va a ser argentino, toma
conciencia de sí mismo y su enorme
potencial que nada más ni nada menos
puede vencer a la mayor potencia del
mundo. Eh, en esa Constitución del
pueblo adquiere un signo profundamente
igualitario. No es cualquier pueblo, es
un pueblo profundamente igualitario y
plebello. Fíjense, Saavedra, Cornelio
Saavedra, que después va a ser el
presidente de la Primera Junta, da un
discurso a los soldados patricios en
diciembre de este año y dice así. Me
atrevo a felicitar a los americanos a
las pruebas que siempre han dado de
valor y lealtad. Se ha añadido esta
última que realzando el mérito de los
que nacimos en Indias convence la
evidencia que sus espíritus no son
inferiores a los europeos españoles que
en valor y lealtad a nadie ceden. 1806,
187, 3 4 años de la revolución de mayo
se está diciendo somos iguales no
solamente a los europeos ingleses, a los
europeos españoles. La idea de el igual
lo equitativo en nuestro pueblo respecto
de quienes supuestamente son superiores
está ya en este momento, nace en este
momento. La última cita ahora sí para
decir que esta victoria indisciplinada
plebella del pueblo argentino sobre la
mayor potencia del mundo, lo que nos dio
también es un orgullo fundamental sobre
nosotros mismos y quien destaca esto es
nada más ni nada menos que Domingo
Faustino Sarmiento, que mucho ha hecho
para combatir a los gauchos, que mucho
ha hecho por traer a Gran Bretaña para
que termine con Rosas y sin embargo no
puede dejar de señalar en el Facundo en
esto. dice, "Hay una virtud a cuidar en
los argentinos." dice que los argentinos
de cualquier clase tengan una alta
conciencia de su valer como nación, que
sea un pueblo con una enorme fe en sí
mismo. Y dice Sarmiento, esta fe en sí
mismo que tiene el pueblo argentino es
una fe que le dejó el despecho y la
humillación que se le impuso a las armas
inglesas, ¿no? Es decir, que los
argentinos podamos tenernos alta estima
nuestra propia nación y nuestro propio
pueblo tiene que ver sin dudas con este
origen del origen que estuvo en las
invasiones inglesas. Sin forma precisa
todavía no hay mapa, no hay bandera, no
hay himno. Sin embargo, lo que hay, lo
que nos deja las invasiones inglesas es
ya un orgullo por la patria de los hijos
de esta tierra.
No, impresionante.
Para mí la mejor columna que hiciste.
[aplausos]
En serio.
No, no. [ovación]
Espectacular.
Impresionante.
Sin parar.
Espectacular.
Sos una capa. M. Es un orgullo ser tu
amigo.
Pero es impresionante.
Ganas estud ganas de ser tu amigo y
tener un fusil. [risas] estudiar
historia. Julita, te quiero mucho. Am
especular.